네 안녕하세요 비산남입니다 제가 오늘
또 성수동에 와 있는데
성수동에
빌딩을 많이 매입한 업체가 있습니다
그 업체는 바로 무신사입니다 그래서
무신사가 지금
엄청 많은 빌딩들을 좀 매입했는데
어떤 빌딩들을 좀 매입했는지 오늘 좀
소개해 드리도록 하겠습니다 지금 뒤에
보이는 저 건물이 무신사가
2019년도에
처음 매입한 건물입니다 그래서 원래는
되게 낡은 공장이었어요 지금 저
건물을 철거를 하지 않고 기존 모습을
좀 살려두고 뒤에를
증축을 했어요
원래 용적률이 좀 더 남아 있긴
하는데
기존의 그 공장 모습을 좀 남겨
두려고 했던 거 같아요 지금 아마
쇼룸으로 좀 쓰고 있는 거 같은데
여기 위치가 그 성수역 바로
나오자마자
코너에 있는 건물이어서 위치가 굉장히
좋습니다 안테나 매장으로 쓰기엔 너무
좋아서 지금이 모습으로 계속 사용하지
않을까 좀 예상이 됩니다 그때 매입할
당시에 돼지 평단가가 한 7천만원
정도의 매입했는데 지금은 제가 봤을
때 거의 뭐 한 2억 2억 5천 그
이상 갈 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다
무신사가 2019년도에는 이렇게 좀
발달되진 않 있었거든요 근데 그때
당시에
싸게 들어가서 지금 시세차익을 많이
봤을 것으로 예상하고 있습니다 지금
이거를 기준으로 여기 인근에 빌딩을
또 매입한게 많이 있거든요 그래서
그것도 현장 가서 설명드리도록
하겠습니다 가시죠 지금 무신사가
매입한 두 번째 건물 앞에 와 있는데
지금 뒤에 보이는 저기 건설 현장이
무신사가
2019년도에
매입한 건물입니다 그래서 지금 철거를
한 상태고
원래는 공장이었어요 그래서
데이지가 되게 큰 공장을 매입을
했는데 그 앞에 이제 작은 건물들이
두 채 있었거든요 근데 그거를
매입하려고
계속 기다렸던 거 같아요 신축을 안
하고 그래서
2020년에 하나 또 매입하고
2021년에 되게 작은 건물까지
최종적으로 매입을 했습니다 그래서 좀
이렇게 반듯하게 맞는 다음에 이제서야
신축을 하고 있는데 대지가 약 한
800평 정도 되고
총 매입가는
580억 정도
됩니다 건물이 올라가면
굉장히 좀 멋진 모습으로 되지 않을까
예상을 하고 있습니다 그래서
연면적이 약한 거의 8천 평 정도
되더라구요 그래서 사옥으로 쓰기에는
너무 좋은 규모의
빌딩이 되지 않을까 싶습니다
근데 지금 뒤에 있는 건물은
연무장길 이면에 있는 건물인데
2021년도에 무신사가
매입한 건물입니다 139억에
낡은 되게 공장 부지를 사서 이렇게
뒤에 보시는 거와 같이 되게 멋지게
신축을 하였습니다 그래서 디자인도
약간 좀
무신사가 좀 추구하는 그런 모던한
스타일로 이렇게 좀 멋있게 신축한
것으로 좀 보여지고요 지금 좀 도로가
좁긴 하지만 사옥으로
활용하기에는 너무 괜찮은 거 같아요
성수역이랑 거리도 그렇게 멀진 않아서
무신사 사옥으로 사용할 것으로 좀
예상이 됩니다 그리고 다음번에 건물은
연무장길 메인에 있는데 그 건물도
한번 좀 가서 보도록 하시죠
지금 뒤에 보이는 건물이 무신사가
이제 초창기에
성수동에 빌딩 투자할 때
낡은 공장 부지를 사가지고 이렇게
뒤에 보이는 거와 같이
멋있게 신축을 하였습니다 그때
당시에는 되게 낡은 공장 부지였는데
여기가
준공업 지역이다 보니까
용적률을 거의 400%까지 신축을
했고 지금 연면적은 한 3,200평
정도
될 것으로 좀 예상이 됩니다 그래서
지하 4층에 지상 10층 정도 규모로
이렇게 신축을 했고 그리고
앞서 보신 거와 같이 좀 이렇게
모던한 스타일로 신축을 했는데 이쁘게
잘 접고 무신사가 추구하는 그런 뭔가
스타일이랑 좀 비슷한 건물이라고
생각을 합니다 그래서 지금 여기 앞에
있는 곳이 이제 연무장 길인데 위치도
굉장히 좋아요 그래서 지금
연무장끼리 지금 호가가 다 이제 2억
정도가 넘습니다네 근데
2019년도에 대지평당 한 5천만원
정도의 매입을 했어요네 그래서 지금
시세는
엄청 많이
올랐습니다네 거의 그때 19년도에
오천에 사서 지금 이제
빵값만 이제 2억이 넘으니까
굉장히 좀 투자를 잘한 사례로 보시면
될 것 같습니다 여러분들 무신사
건물을 좀 다 돌아봤는데 어떠셨나요네
정말 무신사가
2019년도 그러니까 이제 성수동이
막 뜨기 시작한 때부터
진입을 해가지고 지금
굉장한 좀 투자를 잘한
업체라고 저는 생각을 합니다 그래서
건물
지어져 있는 것도 저희가 좀 봤는데
정말 무신사스럽게 건물도 되게 잘
지어놨어요 뭐 아까 보셨던 큰 면적의
짓고 있는 무신사 빌딩도 어떻게
변할지가 되게 궁금한데 그래서
무신사가 앞으로 성수동에서
어떤 모습을 보여줄지 기대가 됩니다
그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요
다음 시간에 뵙도록 하겠습니다
감사합니다